صدمه من ميونخ الى باريس انجاز اوروبي
ينعش خزينه تمييلا يستبعد بوغبا لاسباب
الانضباطيه هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعون
على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
اثارت خساره سان جيرمان امام بايرن ميونخ
في دوري الابطال سخط مشجع الفريق الفرنسيه
على السوشيال ميديا وصبت جماهير باريس
جانا غضبه على اللاعبين في مختلفين
التواصل الاجتماعي بعد الاقصاء للمره
الثانيه على التوالي من ثمن انهاء
المسابقه ونهايه حقبه بانتهاء عقد ميسي في
الصيف المقبل والانباء التي ترجح خروج
نيمار من الفريق شهر يونيو
من جهتها لم ترحم صحيفه نجمه البي اس جي
بعدما نال ليو ميسي تقييمه ثلاثه من عشره
ربما هو الاسوء في تاريخه النجم الشاب
كيليان مبابي ارتدى اشاره القياده خلال
المباراه لكن هو الاخر تلاقي تقييم ثلاثه
من عشره لكي تتوقف عند هذا الحد واعطت
فيراتي اثنين من عشره بعد دوري بشكل سيء
وتسببه بالهدف الثاني
عاشت جماهير ميلان ليله مميزه بتاهل
فريقها الى ربع نهائي شامبيونز لاول مره
منذ عام 2012 وضمن الرسونيري حصول على
حوالي 40 مليون يورو بعد وصوله الى دور
الثمانيه بالاضافه الى المتغيرات التي
يحصل عليها من الرعاه وعيدتي بيع التذاكر
وقد يتجاوز المبلغ 55 مليون يورو ان نجح
مينا في بلوغ المربع الذهبي
لم تهنئ جماهير يوفنتوس بعوده الفرنسي الى
الملاعب بعد استبعاد من القائمه التي
ستواجهنا الالماني في مسابقه الدوري
الاوروبي وكان مدرب الفريق اليغري قد اعلن
استبعاد بوغبا لاسباب الانضباطيه بعد
تاخرها عن اجتماعا للاعبين ويعطي هذا
القرار في الوقت الذي كانت الجماهير تنتظر
مشاركه روما التشكيله الاساسيه للفريق
لانهاء فتره غياب دامت 18